saying if you are
I don't know what I'm doing
about any of it yes you do
you're on to something
Castle this guy's the best assistant
targeting Concepts
he's right that Baron Wasteland junkyard
Planet you don't believe that
Ungar blood confirmed yes come on Simon
Pegg returns
this is how I do it
I'd spread it out
bad that I want her to um solve the
mystery
to connect the dots the introduction of
their relationship is like oh my God
this is like kind of like the office
meets Star Wars like they're just like
two people trying to do good at their
job she's popping pills which I always
respect yeah I know it's like a late
night study session yeah it's not an
addiction if it helps me get an egg Lisa
Simpson at Milhouse yes oh sure I could
help you what are what are big sisters
for
welcome back to new rock stars Star Wars
and or episode five produce how everyone
has their own Rebellion even Indiana
Jones it turns out because the series
keeps shoving in Easter eggs that should
belong in a museum but could Harrison
Ford's other in-universe character
connect to this Rebel conspiracy who
else actually wants to see the ISB
connect the dots is that a bad thing
you'll get your answers when you fix
this and door
this is
exits our weekly and or after so I'm
Eric Voss my Easter egg breakdown of
this episode is going to come tomorrow
but right now I'm here discussing this
episode with Tommy bechtold oh man I
never thought a planning episode could
be so enjoyable an episode that was all
about training and planning it was like
one 36 minute Montage of training but
the relationships in that little Rebel
band are so fascinating and I just like
I'm always you know me I like to look
for the worsted people so I'm always
seeking out who's hiding something in
that group who's the treacherous one
who's a little too quiet who's a little
too bombastic so I don't know I I feel
like uh I feel like we don't have all
the information on all of those
characters and now I thought what I
thought was coming this week will be
coming next week and I just get me the
next Tuesday already see you next
Tuesday ah midnight at midnight
I it's not just in that Rebel band I
mean this and this is I think this is
what good television is right yeah you
don't need major plot shifts to happen
every episode you could just have a
whole episode where you're living with
characters and what makes a good
television is good writing and good
character development yeah and that's
what this episode did because every
character who we talk to who talks to us
it reveals something fascinating about
them about their Outlook and I mean
let's just go through it be by B because
this episode begins with Cyril Karn and
during the nagging of his mother Edie
over a bowl of blue milk soaked in a
cereal that I assume is oops all shame
upon this is really delicious did it not
I was kind of like I wanted they look
great it looked like a mix of booberry
and Cocoa Puffs the idiot in me uh
wanted him to be looking at that puff
and look at the sphere of it and be like
wait a minute the Death Star yeah I
could join the Death Star or operation
no we don't need that Tony Gilroy won't
give that to us he will he will not
he'll give us one TIE fighter
an episode and that's all the old Star
Wars we get that's it that's it and what
uh that was what like I've never seen a
a TIE fighter so terrifying yeah in
context just from the point of view of a
couple Shepherds in a valley we'll get
to that in a second but Edie has what I
think is my favorite line of um this
comedy of manners the scene with his
mother is uh any civilized being knows
that an open invitation is no invitation
at all
what a lot yeah how many open
invitations have I had or been given or
specifically given my parents and that's
how they view it it's like you're not
actually inviting me I was gonna say but
I I I'll be honest I immediately started
doing inventory of the people that had
given with me open invitations and
started going like oh yeah pretty much
to a point it's been like when you
accept this it will inconvenience me so
come by anytime yeah
100 and I thought like oh man I have had
open invitations to given to this person
and yeah that's how they do it that's
what I do with new Rockstar Studios so
I'm like yeah come on by the studio
anytime
you're always welcome here and then I
pull a knife out and I lick the blade uh
all right we we referenced um uh Lisa
Simpson earlier and in one of the later
seasons of The Simpsons she makes fun of
um uh McGill University in Montreal
where March goes oh you could get in
McGill that's the Harvard of Canada at
least it goes anything that's the
something of something isn't really the
anything of anything yeah and I think
that that's a great quote it's it's
Savage but it's great oh yes so Edie's
gonna call Uncle Harlow yeah to get some
prospects for her son Cyril can't help
but glare at cassian's mug shot yeah
throughout all this I I'm so fascinated
to see what happens yes but anyway we
jump to aldani and Cassie wakes up to
find cousin Skeen going through all of
his stuff but skiing hasn't yet found
that kyber Crystal uh skins got some
prison tattoos yeah and we learned that
he and Cassie and Bon over having gone
through the similar I guess Star Wars
equivalent of juvie because it was like
a youth center that they went through
yeah and he calls it like a crate head
so it's like is that like a dragon head
is that like a specific white
supremacist King
in the world oh yeah
the clock but I'm wondering is Andor is
is Cassian lying though because wasn't
he taken in by Marva or do you think
this was pretty he was he was but like
they were criminals and I think and his
dad got hung in the corner and I think
they went on some past job and that's
why they had his mug shot yeah I think
he had a whole a criminal profile saying
he was from best and all that stuff yes
so I think that's where that came well
done Eric well done points to Aaron I
was I was wondering that too I was 10
points to ericdorf but skein says this
great another great line the ax forgets
but the tree remembers now is our turn
to do The Chopping and we find out
there's a deeper context of that later
when his brother was a pepper tree
farmer yes and then he lost his farm and
drowned himself and I love that the
episode's not called the tree remembers
the episode is called the ax forgets
which I just think is fascinating that
they chose to use that part of the
sentence because it's not about the
victims all the stuff which is what you
would think that this episode is all
about the people who are victims it's
about the people who do
the hurting uh that forget about it and
I think that ties in with uh what nimik
later says about like the Imperials just
are so smug that they think they can
just continually oppress us and press Us
in little ways and just by flooding us
with depression that it desensitizes us
to each individual crime
um but again I'm jumping ahead because
one thing I want to point out is how big
of a breakfast episode this was yeah we
everybody had breakfast and I love
that's how we start the day Tony Gilroy
and his brother believe that that is the
most important meal of the day and
they're not really like we got to make
sure everybody knows that even in Star
Wars breakfast is necessary are we gonna
cut to the Albuquerque section the
Albuquerque storyline where Walt Jr's
eating breakfast because I feel like
that's where it's all headed he makes
the bacon into the shape of uh his dad's
birthday yes
um well we need the daughter of mon
mothma in Perrin the teenage leida who
hates her mom and says that man makma
only wants to take her to school to show
off and you know what even though I just
love that teenagers are so perceptive in
this way because whereas a lot of people
just be like oh man my devoted mother
just going through the routine dropping
off her daughter at school
um the daughter's probably on to
something there because Monmouth was
probably using that chore that part of
the routine as part of her routine to
make some visits to connect with some
people and then the fact that the
daughter is now throwing off this
routine freaks out mon Mothman not
because she loses out this opportunity
to hang out with the daughter it's
probably because she's like [ __ ] I was
gonna talk to someone at after school
care and then try to figure out a new
contact to my network my Rebel Network
and you just screwed that up and the
daughter's like no I understand that
you're just doing this for for the show
and I just I just love that yeah
argument there absolutely but correct me
if I'm wrong I mean we're learning that
Monmouth had this shitty husband I don't
know if we knew before this in manmaca
had a teenage daughter and it makes us a
little worried about what's gonna happen
to this family when mon mahama goes
public in her Rebellion should we care I
mean the family kind of sucks but still
it's like another side to her life we
didn't know about it yeah I feel like
Perrin we're all kind of we're preparing
to get a blaster to the to the guts but
uh you know teenager is redeemable maybe
she'll join her mother in the cause
maybe maybe or yeah or maybe she'll like
defect and the mother's like uh all
right well okay blow them all up I guess
um I think my favorite scene this
episode this morning cup of Dre milk
that is some kind of hallucinogen or we
don't know it kills some brain cells
yeah
um nemic shows Cassie in this old school
star path unit I love that we get two
different star path units right we got
the Imperial star path unit it seems
like a big deal but now we have this old
school one and he goes into this
political rant from his literal
Manifesto about the Imperial culture is
so rapidly supplanted everyone's
thoughts that no one has time to even
catch up I mean this is some real truth
let's get this guy in front of a crowd I
mean I've had some breakfast with these
guys before uh you know guys who think
that like certain political figures in
the 2016 cycle were were the first
people to ever say certain things but
actually we're just kind of recycling
some talking points have been around
forever you don't know who I'm talking
about viewers
it could be anyone let's just say that
Namek is feeling the burn and I love
this guy I mean we must protect this guy
at all costs I think because he's he's
speaking a form of truth that no one in
Star Wars has until this point and he
gets it you know what I love about him
is comparing him to Hamilton he gets the
way I do when I'm really on a tear where
he has to like he's like someone's got
to cut me off at some point so I'm gonna
feel this many many talking points in
this until someone comes in and
interrupts me because I don't know how
many other times I'm gonna have to go
into this race
yes I loved it it was a great scene when
he talks yeah it's just a little it's
just a little dance he's like uh a mouse
um walking on a piano trying not to wake
up the Sleeping Beauty he's just a cute
little mouse prancing on a piano it's
just hat dancing like Tom Tom I was at
Tom Cruise and big but no Tom Cruise is
not in big oh Tom Hanks was in big but I
wish Tom Cruise had also been in big
um so Cassie realizes Belle and
tournament don't know how to calibrate
the weight of their escape vessel it
gives him major doubts about their
mission but also proves how essential he
is to the team and I love how more and
more throughout this episode he knows
these little details that they're
actually like [ __ ] we need this guy
because he knows uh he's been so
observant knowing who's right-handed
who's left-handed he I'm actually
staramine about how imps walk
information with her guns on the outside
then this TIE fighter buzzes overhead
they have to hide their guns again this
is like the scariest I think a Tie
fighters yeah oh yeah uh even though
this the sheep or if those are Nerfs I'm
not exactly sure what those things are I
don't think they batted an eye at it no
yeah they're like this happens
I like those little things but I didn't
get I couldn't get a good enough view to
see if they had weird faces or anything
I just saw their big sheep bodies and I
wanted to make a sweater they got uh
those big bodies they got like way too
many horns like there's no evolutionary
advantage to have many that many horns
pointed in different directions but I
mean if we're gonna judge every Star
Wars creature in in that regard would so
many of them be bipedal no no they would
there's no reason no evolutionary
Advantage Vermont calamari to have two
feet that's but it's okay
um so we learned about Lieutenant Gorn a
lot this episode more than I thought we
would but I guess we had 12 episodes why
not explore everywhere I would feel like
we know now where everyone is coming
from and I really love that uh he ranks
really high at this Imperial Garrison on
aldani uh but he poses as this
disciplinary and he tells subordinates
to clean up the temple to take down the
targets these for target practice which
also feels secretly personal for him
like stop shooting at this sacred thing
yeah that was my ex-girlfriend's
favorite spot to hook up right but he he
hides this wistfulness to the land and
its people he makes cigars feel really
lucky to be able to see the eye which I
just thought was such a clever thing you
know like oh you're gonna have to miss
the eyeshadow to repaint this scoundry
and they're like oh no no please
please let us see the eye and he's like
all right good yeah I don't want anyone
in here I wonder if that might blow back
up in his face so I wonder if one was
like you're right I should have
repainted it there'll be another one in
three years I'll catch you to that too
he's just down there painting he's like
yes he's like sorry it's a he's a
beautiful painter and then he just
blasts
he has to
um I just love this little detail that
he fell in love with the local woman but
he lost her it made me want it for a
second like is she telling the truth is
this just something she tells and or to
be like all right everyone's got a good
story including you shut up uh but no I
like to think it's true based on just
off of that look of wistfulness he had
out on him and he's like yeah it is
beautiful isn't it and he was afraid to
be racist you know and the other guy's
like yeah they stink too right and he's
like mine didn't stink yeah all I smell
is the smell of her hair mine smelling
everything reminds me of her
uh we check in briefly on pharynx where
blevin sets up the ambitious Captain
Tigo as prefect and gives them the hotel
to set up his HQ now I have to wonder if
that old man Willie who is like just the
the chatty tourist the chatty
businessman oh yeah and the shuttle
would be like but I got I got my
favorite sweets yeah I don't give up my
room
for everything around here
yeah he's gone back at the ISB denture
mirror under Aid continued their
investigation trying to connect the
Imperial star path unit from steer guard
but with others seemingly unrelated
deaths from Kessel fond or jakku and
base K talk about those more in a second
the rebels break down their Camp hike to
the dam skeem grabs the kyber Crystal
and says Cassian has been lying to them
Cassian I love this twist comes clean
and says that yeah I was paid to be here
what are you gonna do about it you guys
suck you need me yeah and uh and I just
love that they're all like yeah well
maybe you're the scared one he goes uh
yeah okay it's good to be scared but
you're all losing your nerve you bunch
of idiots I just love this detail that
the for the day before is always hardest
if it wasn't me freaking you out it
would have been something else and
you're using me as an excuse to try to
get out of this Mission I I really like
that uh turning the tables I thought
that was great yeah um and then later
skein gives the closest thing to an
apology he can't just telling him what
happened to his brother that was
straight out of the bear that's as much
of his apologies you're gonna get I was
like yeah their cousin Richard's back
well you know because it's probably we
also on a phone call talking about his
daughter who's going through a hard time
at her school that's right I think that
she's a teenager and they're like how
old is she she's like she's five
oh my God
oh my God how is this already happening
um but
um yeah a pepper tree I I wanna how good
was this pepper from the pepper tree for
this part this poor farmer would be like
[ __ ] I can do nothing else now must have
been pretty damn good Peppers well
that's kind of like a there is like a
Hallmark of like if you use the Empire
as like a parallel for like Global uh
malevolent Armed Forces like they're
that's such a common theme in war is
like someone on the bad side gets a
taste for some local fare and they
destroy a family in their legacy so that
they can enjoy like you know the pepper
tree The Apple Tree whatever like you
know Sub in you know like you know the
1940s for for this time it's like yeah
people who have the upper hand or the
power Just impose their will and Destroy
people's lives because of a little
element that makes them slightly happier
oh I like the pepper from this tree I'm
gonna destroy this guy's life absolutely
uh and Val incent to break off from the
group on some side part of the mission
that twice Cassian asked about and they
did not tell him which I think is
interesting uh and we'll we end the
episode back in Lutheran's shop where he
worries about the mission uh that's
happening the next day and uh he reveals
that if also could I just vote out I
know I know it's Star Wars and this is
just a shortcut that he decided to take
a long time ago but I like how
everyone's on the same day and night
schedule pretty much like they're
different plan it's in different solar
systems but they're all on the same day
and night night schedule but I assume
it's like a day to them is a day to
someone there's probably some
translation unit that sure explains they
did mention a calendar in last week's
episode so I'm like oh are they on the
uh like the uh whatever the Roman
Calendar or the Caesar calendar or
whatever yeah like yeah there's
definitely a calendar I yeah I I just
literally figured something out good for
them yeah um but um he says that Vel
orcassian could trace things back to him
but in his shop are just some wonderful
Easter eggs I'll get into more of them
and the breakdown why it's such a big
deal that they're here but we see a Jedi
hologram and a Sith holocron uh and they
are freaking huge these are jumbo size
versus normally these things are a lot
smaller but I guess that just meets all
the animated characters are probably
like eight feet tall right that's the
only way that makes sense because these
things are huge they could be replicas
of them but I don't know why you'd make
a replica of a Sith holocron it's not
really a known thing to the public but I
love it uh as well as and this is you
might have seen these headlines the
Sankara stones from Indiana Jones and
the Temple of Doom and last episode
there was like some Carbonite Indiana
Jones Easter eggs as well they'll get
into the breakdown so yes it's got some
great lucasfilm nods here we'll talk
about how big a deal that is as well
what
what the fact what is the Imperial star
path unit conspiracy that deadro will
soon uncover yeah uh I mean we know
pieces of this we know it has to do with
the rebels but we just don't know how
organized these Rebels are and if these
are all like pieces of a specific puzzle
for one specific Mission or if this is
just like I mean they have to imagine
that there's some kind of Rebel Network
out there they have to be aware they're
aware of like sagarara you know uh but
last episode detrimir Told part of gas
that she that the stolen Imperial Stark
path Universe deer guard was the latest
of a series of uh high profile incidents
of theft but party got shut her down
because she couldn't really prove at
that point they're all connected as part
of some conspiracy she needs to like
figure out that Missing Link of the
Ricoh charges you know that she can get
everyone arrested at the same time but
this episode we learned what the five
pieces of that puzzle are or at least
five five pieces that we know of her Aid
mentions these five cases Castle Ponder
targeting consoles from jakku proton
Warheads from base K and the steer guard
Star Pass unit now of these we gotta
talk about Kessel that might be the most
interesting because only a few years
before this in the Star Wars canonical
timeline were the events of solo a Star
Wars story this is the second solo
reference we've got on the show after
mimbon last episode during that movie
Han Solo Chewie Lando Beckett l337 and
Kira go to Kessel to steal a supply of
coaxium that's the resource used for
Starship Fuel and they steal this for
dry and Voss to replace like another
shipment of coaxim they're supposed to
get for him but then failed because the
the Crimson or not the Crimson the the
cloud riders came in and wrecked it but
Dryden boss represents the Kims and Don
an organization overseen by Maul at this
point in history they successfully steal
this coaxium from Kessel they complete
the Kessel Run and they initially hand
this off to Dryden Voss as it's being
processed it is stolen by infus nest and
the cloud Riders this is a rebel faction
and Han becomes sympathetic to what
they're trying to do now this faction
includes one of the two tubes Brothers
the other two tube is part of sakurera's
partisans and we saw Andrew two tubes in
the trailer for Andor so we know he's
going to show up on the show maybe as
soon as next episode yeah so the the two
tubes brothers are the key to all of
this they are the missing link yeah
between this whole everything in the
show that's right they're Brothers yes
two brothers so I think this must be the
Kessel incident that they're referring
to now it was not part of uh an
intentional conspiracy because they were
trying to steal it for the Crimson Dawn
but that coaxium did end up in Rebel
hands nonetheless and it's probably
doing some pretty good for the rebel
movement fondor what's fondor well
fondor is a planet from which Lutheran
got his founder Hall craft that is that
ship has something weird about it it's
small but it has a unique ability to
travel through hyperspace despite its
small size something that Andor called
out so I think the fact that they are
able to put some hyperspace uh
hyperdrives on these ships is something
that the Empire would worry about now
jakku we all know jakku from the force
awakens this is gonna be the future
location of the battle of jakku the
final throw from the last vestiges of
the Empire against the New Republic
forces
um this is how that's star destroying it
up on Jacob for Ray to scavenge in the
force awakens jakku of course is also
the location of a Sith Observatory The
jakku Observatory of palpatines dealing
with and actually years before this
Palpatine actually started to begin an
archaeological dig there so it's a
Palpatine does have his eye on jakku
there's something happening in a jakku
they talk about like the targeting units
from jakku so now it sounds like there's
like an imperial presence there and then
proton Warheads are what go on the tip
of proton torpedoes they're like you
know pretty powerful explosives
obviously Luke uses proton torpedo to
blow up the Death Star and then now we
have this steer guard star path unit in
uh Lutheran knew that steer guard had
one of these things so he's got like
Connections in all these places now one
could say that these are all unrelated
crimes that indirectly benefit the
rebellion and that um just the fact that
the Rebellion exists is a conspiracy
enough but I think to redeemed deadra
and set her on her path of authority on
this series she's gonna be able to
connect all these crimes behind one
particular face or one particular
regular brand
um so I guess the question now is is
that face going to be Lutheran Royal is
it going to be sagarera uh I think they
already know sagarera exists right
because he's a pretty known entity
during the Clone Wars uh or could the
dot she connects point to the Crimson
Dawn in Maul I mean there's a phrase
when you when you're betting the March
Madness Tournament called you know
betting chalk and that means you're
betting the favorite and I believe that
would be Lutheran in this case and I
have to say I hate to do it because you
know I love an underdog but I think it's
Lutheran I think it'll all connect to
Lutheran because I don't think that he's
I don't I think that character is meant
to kind of I craft finish the molding of
Andor into this guy that we meet in
Rogue one that is like a rebel operative
but also not super devoted to the other
Rebels right like he's devoted to the
cause not the people as much as like you
know he'll gladly just shoot whoever to
like get get where he needs to go or
keep people out of his way so I think
Lutheran is the last piece of that
puzzle for him to fully turn him into uh
a rebel operative but not uh but one
that lacks the like Brotherhood or or
personhood uh kinship with the other
Rebels yeah
um I agree I think it is Lutheran I
think it's going to be his connection
with saw Guerrera and with the other
Rebels that uh is most exposed I think
the fact that this season is taking
place across like the first year of
andor's five years towards Rogue one uh
tells us I I would be surprised if
Lutheran survives this season me too
just because he's not really he's not
there during Rogue one right uh so he's
gonna die at some point on the show
would be my guess yeah here's my Grim
theory for what's gonna end up happening
I think uh dead Ramiro is going to be
successful in her investigation she's
going to use the on uh the discovery of
Lutheran and and what he's been doing to
advance her career it's gonna things are
gonna Trace back to Lutheran either
through Vel or Cassian or something else
because even with Cassian he wasn't
careful so if he wasn't careful with
Cassie and how many other times was he
not really careful I think in order to
preserve what she's doing we know it's
the the Gorman Massacre that causes mon
Mothman have to leave uh formally her
position and then publicly join the
Empire or publicly joined the Rebellion
I think mon Mothman is going to have to
publicly turn on Luther ah I think he's
gonna go to her and say I have been
exposed in order to preserve your
position you have to go in front of the
Senate and say Oh there's uh basically
have your McCarthy list and say we have
a spy amongst us and throw me under the
bus wow but he has such nice trinkets at
his shop such wonderful trinkets I think
I think this season's going to end with
that shop getting burned yeah because
that's the only way to justify uh these
ridiculous Easter eggs or maybe
basically say they're forgeries or
something I kind of want to look I want
to see if anything from the uh from the
shop is in the Trading Post in the Star
Wars holiday special you know when
they're going around oh yeah he's
showing off all the gadgets I'm like I
wonder if there's any overlap there
that'd be a fun way to connect I'm sure
no I think I think that's the only way
because like her driver has brought her
to this antique shop and it's like he
gets exposed right like there's no way
that she doesn't also get her hands
dirty unless unless she turns against
him publicly and then it's gonna break
her heart obviously they have to do that
I think that's where I mean if I were
Tony Gilroy that's where I would take
this absolutely I I think I think you're
right on I think that it is going to be
I mean Star Wars is kind of all about
these like sacrifices right and like and
and sacrifices that are kind of hidden
within other sacrifices so it's like
Lutheran is sacrificing himself Monmouth
is sacrificing Lutheran like you know
what I mean like it's it's all it's all
this interconnected for the good of the
Rebellion so I I think you're dead on I
think that that is uh probably the most
logical
thing I also think we're probably not
done with some of the characters we've
met I I theorize some of those Rebels
are going to mess up the the thing on
purpose I think there's a mole in that
Rebel band right now I can't figure out
who I've been studying intently but I
don't yet have my my favorite maybe I'll
predict before next week's episode but
uh before then how about we give a
thanks to a sponsor would that be all
right we want to thank better help for
sponsoring Wikileaks today and for
sponsoring me personally how can my well
that maybe they sponsored the channel
then I use their cool code how we care
for our minds affects how we experience
life so it's important to invest time
and Care into keeping them healthy there
are plenty of ways to support a healthy
brain like learning a new language or
taking power naps I love the latter I
take power naps or some people call them
full REM cycle sleeps there's also
better help online therapy better help
is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat only therapy
sessions so you don't have to see anyone
on camera if you don't want to it's much
more affordable than in-person therapy I
like I have said on this show and others
have begun using better help I've been
in it about two months now and it's not
just my appointments my weekly
appointments are great they're very
helpful but there's stuff within the
week that I do kind of stay on track and
my and my therapist is available for
texting we do a video appointment once a
week then we text she gives me homework
I don't like that that's probably part
of the problem she she clocks that she
goes he's being very stubborn about his
homework she gives me more homework we
fight there's no grades uh at the end of
the day we both end up crying that's not
true she does a great job I cry no
matter what I cry during Apple
commercials during Christmas when
Frankenstein sings there's no place like
home for the holidays anyway I'm off
track here our listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
Wookie that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash Wookie and make sure
you use that code because when you use
that code it helps us keep the lights on
at Old Wikileaks and you don't want to
see the space with low lighting I got to
be in HD
well Tommy there's no place like you for
a Wednesday that's right I want you to
or any day of the week thank you all
right let's uh dig into this question of
the Indiana Jones Easter eggs because
like I I just want to clear up like what
canonicity means when these Easter eggs
show up on Star Wars this week we got
the Sincara stones last week's episode
you know I didn't point this out but
there is uh Indy's whip Frozen the
Carbonite a few other things that I'm
going to point out in the breakdown
these Easter eggs are included because
Star Wars films share a lucasfilm
connection with Indiana Jones George
Lucas was also a director in Indiana
Jones and these along with Willow
they're all part of the lucasfilm family
yes and these kind of cross-referential
Easter eggs far predate any of the
Easter eggs that you're seeing in the
MCU or other franchises like that and as
such they have a different canonical
classification in Raiders of the Lost
Ark on a golden surface covered in
hieroglyphics near where Indy finds the
Ark of the Covenant C3PO and R2D2 are
carved in there too because that
literally mean C3PO and R2D2 were there
in ancient times no it does not good but
it it's not it's more of a joke yeah
George Lucas is doing there Andy's
getaway plan in the opening sequence of
Raiders is the call sign is OB CPO uh in
Temple of Doom the Shanghai Club it's
called Club Obi-Wan in the Last Crusade
on the boat that Indy retrieves across
the Coronado from it has a barrel with
the Portuguese word for Carbonite in
Solo a Star Wars story which we were
talking about among the treasures and
Dryden boss's collection is the golden
idol from Raiders Star Wars titles often
use sound effects from the same
lucasfilm audio library as the indie
films do like the sounds of jet engines
firing up and this [ __ ] gets even
weirder George Lucas put the E.T
speeches
literally a character walking around in
the background so lucasfilm titles just
have a long tradition of referencing
each other and in the works of their
friends to pay homage but not to imply
these things are canonically connected
Easter eggs to establish
interconnectivity wasn't really a thing
until franchises like the MCU and I
would say the Dave filoni side of the
Star Wars Universe yeah so it sets up an
interesting distinction when Dave
flooney and John Favreau are working on
a Star Wars property so whether that's
the book of Boba Fett or the Mandalorian
or Ahsoka I think we could take the
Easter eggs seriously because I think
they really are trying to do that World
building with the Easter eggs yeah but
things like uh like other Star Wars
titles things that I've ever seen by
George Lucas or in this case uh and or I
don't I don't think these Star Wars
Easter eggs are definitely saying like
these are the same lothal tablets that
Ezra had right well that kind of makes
sense though if you think about it
because Favreau got his start in the end
well not his start but his Blockbuster
Big franchise buildings tight in the MCU
so he's kind of just carrying that over
to his side of the street there you're
totally right and I think it's also the
case with animators I think animators
are have and that's filoni's background
they have more fun trying to say oh
these things are connected this is the
same thing like the Pixar Easter eggs do
that as well Rick and Morty Easter eggs
do this like Rick and Morty imply that
Gravity Falls takes place in the same
universe uh they I think animators like
to imply that all these people kind of
live together yeah uh whereas like in
this case I think they're putting in
props just as like a nod to fans and
that's that's really all we're meant to
take it absolutely but we see things
like Indiana Jones Easter eggs does it
take you out of it is my question no I I
don't have that uh level of detail and
I'm I'm very much watching what's
happening on the surface I'm looking
around but I you know as I've worked at
new rock stars for a few years now I've
become better at noticing Easter eggs
but on the first view I'm just soaking
it in I you know I I do think the
excitement I get when I notice an Easter
egg uh can take me away for just a
second but it doesn't ruin the viewing
experience to me I especially the non
the you know the kind of canonical nods
rather than like
interconnecting things canonically I
think those are fun I love that C-3PO
and R2D2 are on the walls in in on Earth
in India in an Indiana Jones movie
doesn't bother me I think it's great not
to each other you know there's so many
people that work on these movies it just
must be delightful for them I I think as
a as a fan that just kind of loves this
stuff without going too deep into it I
it doesn't bump me I like it how about
you yeah I I honestly think this is what
Easter eggs are supposed to be they're
supposed to be hard to find yeah they're
supposed to give you a greater
appreciation you have to like understand
what context is like with the person who
placed it there right and what it means
for like the people who are working on
it uh and it and it has to uh be
specific it has to be intentional and so
many times like just because like uh a
lot a love cat walks into frame like oh
it's an Easter egg it's not an Easter
egg and it's like right there in front
of you if they do a close-up shot of a
wall and there's a Spider-Man on the
wall and they focus in on the wall
that's more like a like a chicken's egg
than an Easter egg like it's just okay
it's an egg it's an egg it's a quail egg
it's not Easter though you're not
hunting for it
um I think uh the only thing is I wish
that these I don't mind in Indiana Jones
Easter egg in there I just wish that it
wasn't in the same shop as like the
loath tablets just because they they
have such specific uh meaning to the to
Ezra Bridger into the lore from uh from
Star Wars Rebels so like that's the only
all the other items I'm like totally
fine totally fine to have placoon's mask
right totally fine to have a gungan
shield uh the Starkiller armor because
even the Starkiller armor it's like
modified there's like other parts to it
uh I just wish that those tablets
weren't there because those are those
are like specific those are important
yeah um but whatever I don't really care
at the end of the day it's fun I think
that uh with any Easter egg you have to
to take in the context of people who are
making the property that's what I mean
context context context is so important
to like when a detail shows up and
something you have to think about the
person who put it there and who in the
crew put it in there
um and in this case like what is Tony
Gilroy trying to do right with with
Andor is it trying to build out an
interconnected Universe the way that
felony and Favreau are doing with Amanda
Morgan no no he's trying to tell a very
specific story to very specific
different kind of is this just his way
of being like hey I'm not giving you
your normal Star Wars pudding so here I
was like here's here's a glass of Star
Wars Nostalgia and some Lucas Films
Nostalgia just to kind of wash my new
pudding down you know as uh like yeah it
wouldn't even surprise me if Tony Gilroy
has no idea what these things like it
wouldn't surprise me if there's just
like the guy like Pablo and the other
guys in the team are just like here
they're like we're putting this stuff in
there and he's like fine right cool I
don't know whatever okay but getting
back to like the the plot and the meat
in this episode velencenta Yeah the
secret part of the mission what do you
think it is I don't know because it's
crazy to separate Sinta from the team
when she's the one that can medically
take care of them right like they're
she's the Healer she's the Healer she's
the kind of doctor so
whatever it is it seems very specific
that it needs to be female right so to
me maybe that's something with the tribe
the truck maybe there's an element of
infiltrating the tribe that's going to
be celebrating the eye maybe there are
no females working in that Garrison I
don't know I haven't seen a female
Empire officer empirical officer there
yeah I don't know I think my to me it's
got to be their their either they're
going to be posing as people that are a
part of that local tribe and then maybe
wandering into the Garrison and getting
into you know causing a diversion that
would be my best guess yeah I like this
idea that it's coming in through the the
tribe specifically yeah they're gonna
oppose as uh because they don't have
another Imperial outfit for them so they
may be because we know that like they're
expecting some locals to show up like
they're saying oh last time there was
like a hundred of them can you imagine a
thousand of them so I think that they
might be bledding in with the locals and
then yeah you're right maybe there's
like some Priestess Society who conducts
some kind of ritual and that's how
they're going to be part of it the
witches of Gotham here maybe they're
gonna be witches yeah
uh-huh yeah the and the fact that it's
like Vel and Sinta who are quizzing him
on like I think Sinta also knows the
aldani language so I think that that
makes a lot of sense my mind did
unfortunately jump to like oh maybe they
have to seduce some of the uh so like
they have to specify oh yeah I don't
know if that would happen on the show
like this is like yeah it's not like
Marion and Raiders uh but no I like that
idea that yeah they're part of mission
uh and but I also just like this idea
how on this Mission not everyone knows
every part of the plan right which is
great like Lutheran's the only one I
think who knows all of it yeah
um which is smart Okay Uncle Carlo oh
yeah what do you think he has in store
for cereal Karn I I don't have a great
answer for that but I hope he's played
by Oliver Platt and I hope he's playing
the same character as the uncle in the
bear and even though cousin Richie is
off uh doing a heist right now I hope
they run into each other at some point
he's like God Richard not you again and
then Richie's like [ __ ] off uh sorry
half off this Uncle Harlow to me seems
like first of all it seems like he's not
actually his uncle right like it's like
Cyril's kind of like he won't even
remember us like you know like which to
me implies like almost a mafioso
presence but and especially if he's like
placing him somewhere like they're like
like when Cyril's like what does he have
in mind for me or whatever and she's
like he wants to observe you first
that's so weird I I imagine he's some
sort of like Intergalactic gang like
Mafia Chieftain or something like that
so I I would say he's gonna have he's my
bet is that between the mother and Uncle
Harlow they're gonna try and turn Cyril
into like a like distinguished criminal
and then he's gonna break off of them
and join the Empire that's my prediction
see I had a hot take while I was
watching this what if because Cyril's
just so aimless right now and he seems
to have really poisoned his reputation
with the Empire right what if Uncle
Harlow is part of the Rebel Network oh
God I was like hey you want to fight
this from the other side oh why don't
you join this organization Cyril becomes
a protest becomes a good guy in this
well well what if he just joins the
rebellion in some other operation
they're like we just need every hand we
can get oh yeah and then so okay so we
joined imagine this he joins like a
rebel faction he ends up on the same
Mission as Cassian oh God and in that
moment he's like you ruined my life and
it could be that Cyril blows the entire
Mission like he we could see like a semi
Redemption tale for the character where
he's joining the Rebellion but he
Harbors in his heart this hatred for
Cassie and Edward and he can't let it go
so that could be the the ghost in the
machine yeah is that you have this like
personal Grudge that this character
harbors and can't let go of but for
right now I don't see like I don't think
his track record's that messed up yeah
they could try to exploit him to join
the Rebellion I think it should be
useful to them absolutely because I just
don't imagine how he rejoins the Empire
that's true or rejoins the baddies like
I feel like the only path for him now is
although I will say the actor has a big
beard now so maybe he grows a beard and
like maybe he just has a little beard
when they're filming and he like he
becomes like like you know on movies
when someone grows a beard they become
unrecognizable they're like oh this is
Kiro sarn
he's a new recruit he's got a good Cyril
corn no you're Carol shut up well we
will leave it there for ever zone of
voice breakdown is coming out coming out
tomorrow Tommy and I will be back next
Wednesday with our reaction episode six
of Andor follow me at EA vasolo Tommy
and Tommy back told follow a new
Rockstar subscribe to WikiLeaks wherever
you get your podcast thanks for watching
and spoken